and now there's even a new study out
today that talks about this unconscious
bias training showing how essentially it
doesn't do anything but creates
a worse of a problem which is something
that really needs to be talked about
because
uh no one really wants to touch that
topic at all we have we have a story
here from real clear science
research shows diversity training is
ineffective you don't say
um to everybody listening i i just want
you to imagine that you're at work
you know maybe you're you work in an
office common job your computer
and they say it's time for your your
mandated corporate diversity training
what's the first thing every single
person thinks or
90 of them when they're told this is
what's going to happen a guy in a suit
well no no just any person any average
person ugh exactly
i think of the office the office space
segment when they had their diversity
training do you remember that clip
no it's been a while like it's it's i
don't want to spoil it
yeah nobody wants nobody cares they're
like corporate drugs
if anything i'd imagine it made it worse
that's what the study found it found
that it
did make race relations worse i mean
already let's be honest here a lot of
the woke people they're very
uncomfortable around people of color
already
but imagine minutes yes yes they're very
patronizing
a lot of times yeah they're patronizing
a lot of the times they're
awkward they're weird and if you treat
someone differently because of their
skin color
obviously you're not going to gel or
work with them as if you just treat them
like a normal human being which is which
a lot of people are forgetting and
they're not doing at all well black
lives matter drove a
whole bunch of hispanics over to the
right too yeah that was crazy
so we it was it really interesting we
had uh you know you know hunter avalon
yeah what is that about
we had him on the show the other day and
uh you know he he's nice but he's
he's very like he said he's like now
he's been conservative now he sent her
center left he voted for biden i'm like
but uh you know he was talking about how
he's very much in favor of the
traditional family
and i'm like so you so you opposed black
lives matter and he's like ah no
no i'm like yes or no black lives matter
explicitly
in there they're doing the was it the
new york teachers union did that uh
curriculum yeah the black lives matter
curriculum
where they oppose the traditional family
it's not just the parent organization
it's like the general
group and what they espouse they do not
like traditional families
so you know to even go back to the
discussion it's very
clearly a divide between what these
countries are new york
very very different from say west
virginia but he's he
he doesn't recognize that i think one of
the big issues is that
you tell somebody racism is bad and
they're going to be like i like that
that's correct i don't like racism great
but then what they're really doing is
see the woke left definition of the word
racism
is like or is literally them being
racist or i should say
they call it anti-racism and it's the
same exact thing as racism
the only real difference is what their
stated intent is i suppose
so they're advocating for one thing
calling it something else and then
having people do these trainings who
clearly don't like it no it doesn't make
everything worse make everybody hate
each other
yeah if you're if you're gonna tell
someone that someone else is bad
you're doing a bad thing so you're the
bad one
saying that guy's bad so it's like if
you're gonna use
evil to call out evil you're the evil
one well basically they're like
racism is bad our solution is to judge
people on the basis of their race
it's like okay who was it ibra max kendy
who was talking about how the only way
to make things right was just to be more
biased against white people
this doesn't seem like the way forward
no he said discrimination against
everybody
oh everyone yeah yeah it's truly equal i
like that well yeah
sorry not good um in the schools they've
been pretty much
teaching white kids to hate themselves
yes and that that's the thing that
really drives me over the edge and
thank god i homeschool but um they're
they're teaching people not to
credit edison with light bulbs cartoon
network put out a thing about that
and like all these things that are just
like little digs at white kids
and it's gonna make white kids feel bad
and hate themselves they added
their skin but the edison thing is
interesting so they're they're they're
saying it was some black dude who
invented the lipo bag oh yeah
but it was actually that he and i think
he perfected a filament right that
improved upon it and i'm pretty sure
didn't he work for edison i'm going to
look around not sure
i'm so my understanding of when it
happened over while the cartoon played
but it's it's not a black lives matter
thing it's a socialism thing it's a
communism thing yeah
he invented it but he was working for
edison edison like said here's what
we're doing here's our brother anyone oh
okay and then he improved
on the on the project project and they
credit it's about crediting the worker
versus crediting the owner you see
ah yeah yeah his name's louis howard
latimer and uh he was an american
inventor pat and draftsman for the
patents of the incandescent light bulb
among other inventions i could go deeper
into it yeah but wasn't it actually
invented he just
made like the new filament yeah or used
the most used filament of the time yeah
but my understanding is that isn't isn't
the original light bulb still on it's
always been on
it's in a firehouse in new york city or
something like that yes and because of
planned obsolescence we're now given
light bulbs that we have to keep
buying again and again yes that's that's
that's i guess like the
the typical thing here on the internet i
i think the official answer was that it
was completely impractical to build
because it was expensive and hard to
produce
but i also think you got a guy makes a
light bulb and says these things
basically light up forever and they're
like so what we run a company for a year
and then we're done
good point can we get something that
fails and now here's the best part
that's that's the guy who invented the
filament that we used for like 100 years
was he the one who who who perfected the
obsolescence
so they're trying to credit him for
making a light bulb when in fact he may
he may be the guy who's credited
for creating the bad light bulbs that
cause rampant pollution
and consumerism and you know basically
emboldened capitalism
i'm not saying that's true i'm just
saying you know if we if i i heard the
story there's a firehouse in new york i
guess it's a light bulb it's been on
forever
it's still on yeah i heard about that as
well yeah i don't know if that's true i
don't know whatever i've been thinking
a lot about uh secession since that we
came up a little bit earlier
and i think that maybe a better thing
would be a revolution
against uh taxes
that are imposed unjustly you know i
don't i don't
th that's not going to solve the culture
world argument like
sales or like like what is that the
payroll tax what does that do with like
kids getting puberty blockers
well i know i'm just kind of jumping
track right here and taking us taking it
back to where it was like
20 minutes ago has nothing to do with
that people but those are those are the
issues for the culture
state solution listen
kids are crazy because we've been at war
for fight because we want to extract
opium
and oil for money so if we can get out
of this fiat realm
of the opec dollar and stop worshiping
the dollar
then i think well it won't be so crazy
because we won't have to go to war
the one thing that may drive an actual
divorce is the fact that the popular
left and the populist right don't care
for any of that stuff and it's only the
neo libs and neocons who are like yay
war
so you give you give you know the bernie
sanders crew the opportunity but we
don't care about that
we want people to have health care and
you go to the conservatives and trump
supporters and like bring our jobs back
like i don't see any of the bernie
people being like yay war
well some of them but not like the legit
progressives
and the trump supporters definitely not
so if if there's
if there's one thing that's going to
drive a peaceful split is when both
populist factions tell the establishment
we don't care about you anymore and we
don't agree
and we don't like those people either
but we agree not to interact anymore
i think the real issue is we could have
a weakening of the federal government
we don't need a peaceful split we don't
need a civil war or revolution
we need the supreme court to stop being
able to dictate laws for the entire
country
right that's really great that's
federalism yeah
if because i was thinking about i was
reading a lot about the the uh
uh revolution and american independence
you know that a bunch of people in new
york signed a declaration of dependence
they were like we don't want revolution
we we love the king so like 500 and
something people signed this no one
knows because
well you know we won and they didn't so
but uh but anyway
the the original articles of
confederation in the u.s extremely weak
it was basically like all the states
with whatever authority they had said
we're gonna fight for each other so that
you know we're all independent
and then after that you kind of do your
own thing with the constitution
they were all like okay now we're one
country and we have to you know we have
these rules we have a supreme court we
have legislation and stuff like that
it affects everybody i guess that was a
decent idea
but now now what's happening is we can
still provide for the common defense
we can still do what the federal
government was supposed to do in
collecting taxes
and you know providing military and you
know negotiations on behalf of all the
states
but does it make sense that half the
states completely disagree with half the
states
on certain key issues and the supreme
court says we hereby rule that everyone
must abide a certain way
while i certainly agree with a lot of
the rulings of the supreme court because
they've benefited me and my family like
going back to the 60s and civil rights
and stuff like that
the problem now is that the cultural
issues are so like stark and completely
out of this world
that i mean we're on the verge of people
when we're literally watching people
kill each other and beat each
other in the street if we just said okay
west virginia you can have your guns and
do your thing
okay you know and if people don't like
it you can move somewhere else
but it's weird the left are the ones
advocating for saying like all states
must conform to one uniform law in this
country
even though they don't live in these
states yeah if california wants to give
up their guns i don't care just stay out
of west virginia
right yeah if someone wants to be this
armed and live with a bunch of rats
around them they could go to new york
city you know
go right ahead feel free to support
those
incentives and i think really you hit on
a good point here
decentralization i think is a peaceful
way to resolve a lot of this and i think
if there ever was an
opportunity to make people realize that
independence
state states rights are very important
it is right now
i think we have a very big opportunity
to remind everyone we don't need a
huge big bloated bureaucratic federal
government
centralizing and controlling everything
we see what happens with the dmv
it's not a good idea less less
government is
good and it allows people to prevail it
allows people to thrive and allows
people to of course
not be squashed and screwed over by all
the big multinational corporations that
are using government to their own
personal benefit
and a lot of people have it skewed
they're saying the corporations are evil
we need more government
no you fool you don't understand that
it's because of big government
and their incentives and their programs
and their one-on-one
working with them that has established
them to be these big giants that they
are right now and why we're living in
this current situation that we are
it's because of direct government
intervention
you know i was i've been i've been
talking about uh for a while about
the track towards the civil war and
seeing like
half the states align against the other
in a you know
almost making the supreme court or osu
was documented on the supreme court
springfield
rejected it just shows that there is
serious alignment between the left the
republican republicans democrats left
right
against each other you know based on the
stuff we were talking about with like a
new occupy wall street
i'm wondering if it's not going to be a
civil war but a revolution and what i
mean by that is
it'll look more like what happened to
syria than like the civil war in this
country
we have a political establishment you
have people like joe biden he's filling
the ranks like
joe biden unity did the moment they said
joe biden is the president-elect he was
like all right he got a fire truck
and he hooked the the hose right into
right into a big old swamp and started
spraying dc
down full blast the firehouse tandon
he is filling the swamp with a fire hose
so you know what i'm talking about the
left and their autonomous zones
like you said you don't care if
california bans guns just stay away from
west virginia okay
so now you got this town in washington
why would they interfere with what
portland's doing you voted for it that's
your you go do your thing
so what happens then when the polit when
the establishment tries to maintain
control over all of them
and then you get something like you know
right-wing individuals writing militias
saying to lefting militias
hey you don't like like we saw with the
boogaloo boys
and black lives matter and antifa there
was this rally in the west coast where
the boogaloo boys were like shaking
hands with antifa
and they were like look we disagree with
you but we all agree the government's
bad right they're like yeah
and there's there's a video i think it's
from ford fisher where the antifa guy is
like
you stood with us today and we respect
you for that and so what happens
those people will say we don't want to
go to your your town or your your state
we want our state and and the boogaloo
boys and the right-wing are like we
completely agree
it's the establishment and the
government you know the the mainstream
political establishment it's bad so in
that sense
if we if it comes down to like these
coveted lockdowns destroying people's
lives
you're gonna and and the michigan police
blocking the gop from coming into the
capital building they shut it down
then republicans are eventually going to
be like why am i going to support these
police
then when antifa and black lives matter
go and fight the cops and say do you
phone the police
conservatives going to be like okay i'm
already seeing it yeah
like i've been i've been covering this
stuff a lot and
i think i had tweeted out like the
michigan video of them being denied
entry
my mentions are all republicans being
like why are we back in blue
yeah let's stop back in the blue i don't
back the blue anymore and
i it's it's getting to a point but the
problem is there's different
the reasons are very different so i
don't think there'll be an alliance
necessarily
no but if the enemy of the enemy is my
friend
and you know the cops are doing
something bad
then the republicans are going to be
like i'm not getting involved
so i i don't think the the right i
shouldn't say republicans i keep saying
that
the trump supporters or the populist
right i don't think they're going to
show up to portland and be like we've
come to supply aid in your fight against
the establishment maybe at some point
i think mostly they're gonna sit back
put their feet up and be like
we ain't helping you you're on your own
officer why don't you go lock down some
poor working family's business so they
go starve to death
i'm not going to support that i
personally will not support that
and so the more i see these cops like in
staten island barring people from
their first amendment rights i'm like
sorry i'm not going to support those
cops by all means antifa
do your thing i don't care defund them
whatever i don't live there if you voted
for it well that's you know you live
there
but if it was invaded by like a foreign
country would you still come to
their aid that's an interesting question
because at one point i probably would
have said yes
at this point man i don't know if if
new york destroys everything and their
government destroys everything
maybe you know for the people not the
establishment government
or maybe i just might just be like well
this is what happens when you lose
support of the people and they no longer
feel the government represents them
someone could come in and invade and i'm
going to be like
it's not a government for me they don't
i've never been a republican they never
represented me
joe biden certainly doesn't none of
these people do so why would i do
anything
i'm not a part of that community yeah
the bigger question is who would want
new york city no one wants the hell who
i lived there i moved away from there
for for a particular reason
i'd rather would rather live in my
parking lot yes
i'm a lot happier here my rv's bigger
than my apartment was in new york city
i mean uh yeah and new york's flooded
during sandy yeah yeah i was there tim
was there as well
there yeah yeah that was crazy you know
um one thing the government i think is
overreaching and over
doing it's a little bit too much is uh
forcing us all to use the same currency
and if they would just back off and let
us decentralize command here
but you can that's that's not true i
mean the us dollar is the national
currency so what
ithaca has to
there's a bunch of jurisdictions with
local currencies there's a big movement
breaking ridge dollars well that's
awesome and there's cryptocurrencies
there is but they regulate the hell out
of it and i don't think they should
the issue i think was there was one guy
you look do you remember that i did the
liberty dollar
remember that yes he got raided but i
guess was because he was printing money
and calling it dollars and currencies
what i'm talking about but that's
that's not the so when you look at
places like ithaca they have
it's not really big anymore i went there
you know a year two ago and asked them
about it they said it still exists
but it kind of fell out of disuse
because the main proponent and they
could have done it if they just didn't
put dollars on there
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you